now the next awards are for costume
design during the past dozen years
Hollywood has set a pattern of fashion
the clothes worn by our feminine stars
seem to create the type of styles women
like to follow and to present the awards
we have the type of women men like to
follow from my left Miss Piggy down
and for my rapist Joe Andrew
thank you Paul
we're very pleased to visit the wards to
the desires and for all the women who
appear on the screen we would like to
thank the people who make that
appearance so much better
those nominated for the best achievement
in costume design for a black-and-white
production are the eros Paramount Edith
Head and guile Steele and Prince epoxies
20th Century Fox Vittorio Nino novo race
a and the winner is Edith Head and all
these wonderful ladies and gentlemen I'm
so happy for you to say
the ward is long overdue
safe place this afternoon and I told her
I was rooting strongly for her and here
she comes with a very interesting gown
black linen skirt with a white top of
the writers
guille steel was also accepting the
award edith crews nominated in 1948 for
the emperor walls though is nominated
for the best achievement in costume
design of a color production our
adventures of don juan Warner Brothers
Leah Rhodes Traviata and Marjorie best
and mother as a freshman 20th Century
Fox K Milton the envelope please
the winner is Leah Rhodes Sevilla and
Marjorie best for the adventures of jar
of Don Juan
be happier there Rhodes is doing the
costumes for the new picture I'm about
to start now and she's done some
wonderful things out of Warner Brothers
and travillian has to also Margery best
the two ladies are coming up to us
accept the award I'd like to describe
what they have on but from our little
canary cage it's
Thank You Peggy Dow enjoy Andrew Leah
Rhodes and Marjorie best have accepted
the award for trivia